how is marvel's black panther franchise
going to continue without chadwick
boseman and what's with that strange
ceremony with everyone wearing white
keep watching to find out more small
details you may have missed in the black
panther wakanda forever trailer
it's a remarkable achievement that black
panther wakanda forever even made it to
the finish line chadwick boseman who
plays t'challa aka black panther in the
first film passed away at the age of 43
in 2020 leaving behind shoes that were
impossible to fill
there aren't words
to express
what an amazing human being chadwick
boseman was
marvel fans everywhere were captivated
by his performance in black panther and
it's one of the many factors that led to
the film being nominated for several
academy awards in 2019. fortunately
marvel opted not to try and recast
another actor as t'challa instead it
appears the studio will center the
sequel story around t'challa's younger
sister shuri his mother queen ramonda
nakia okoye and other characters from
the 2018 movie all the while finding a
way to honor the legacies of bozeman and
his character at least that's what it
looks like based on the first trailer
for black panther wakanda forever that
debuted on saturday evening at san diego
comic con 2022 the teaser trailer for
the second black panther feature
indicates there is still plenty of life
left in this beloved franchise in
addition to boasting plenty of important
characters from the previous movie the
teaser introduces the audience to some
new players and hints at other mystical
worlds away from wakanda there's plenty
to unpack so let's take a look at some
of the smaller details you may have
missed the first third of the black
panther wakanda forever trailer shows
wakanda in a state of mourning for their
late king and most recent black panther
t'challa in the wake of bozeman's death
ryan coogler director of both black
panther installments addressed the
packed sdcc 2022 convention hall and
told fans that bozeman's legacy will
last far beyond the tragic early end of
his life he said i promise you i feel
his hand on me right now chad's passion
and the genius and his culture and the
impact he made on this industry will be
felt forever t'challa's absence hangs
heavy over the beginning of the trailer
we get brief glimpses of shuri nakia
okoye and his mother queen ramonda in
various displays of sadness or stoism
while soul sensation thames delivers a
mournful cover of bob marley's no woman
no cry it is very clear that t'challa's
absence cuts deep in the lives of
everyone who knew him loved him and
fought beside him leaving them all to
shed a tear privately or come together
as one
and my entire family
is gone we also see a large ceremony
featuring a cadre of dancers and a
ceremonial procession but everyone wears
white as such it's unclear if this is a
funeral procession for t'challa a
wedding for sure perhaps or something
else entirely as you would expect from
the most senior surviving member of the
wakandan royal family romanda is leading
by example as the stone-cold and
determined figurehead of the nation
after being separated from both her
children during the blip in avengers
infinity war and then happily reunited
with them at the end of avengers end
game the stress has clearly taken a toll
on her based on the wisps of white hair
poking out from under her headdress as
she gazes across the beach raimonda
appears to be navigating the very public
very exacting duty of leading a nation
while struggling with the death of her
son it's a tough road ahead for the
queen but she has the support she needs
to get her through this includes her
daughter shuri who is by her side and
ready to put on a strong front but it
doesn't seem like the wakandan princess
will focus much on her brilliant
engineering skills or at least they'll
take a back seat to more important
matters at one point in the black
panther wakanda forever teaser trailer
we see her participating in the royal
duties including taking part in what
appears to be a funeral procession
unless it's something more celebratory
and recruiting help from riri williams
yes that's right fans will meet
ironheart before she takes the spotlight
in her upcoming solo disney plus series
of the same name of all the exciting
details that the new teaser for black
panther wakanda forever offers seeing
neymar and the rest of the atlanteans
for the first time will probably make
marvel fans jump right out of their
seats not even one minute into the
trailer fans can see what appears to be
an atlantean couple giving birth to a
new child which could possibly be a
young neymar in a haunting shot just
past the one minute mark it appears that
atlanteans and what might be a young
neymar are watching a building burn it
then immediately transitions to him
walking out of the water as an adult
appearing far more stately and adorned
with additional atlantean regalia we
also get plenty of shots of the
atlantean community the trailer isn't
shy with its breathtaking shots of the
underwater way of life the citizens of
atlantis live scenes of a crew of
atlanteans riding a humpback whale and a
squad of atlantean fighters facing off
against an unseen foe on dry land are
sure to stick in our minds until we see
this movie marvel comics atlanteans have
been around on earth for some time along
with neymar although they technically
immigrated from the planet vauden long
ago namor is the son of a human father
and an atlantean princess he is also one
of the most powerful and intelligent
beings in the marvel universe in fact in
marvel comics namor has been part of the
illuminati the group that makes their
live-action debut in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness wanna stop
you've possessed an innocent woman but
you can still do the right thing
let her go it will be interesting to see
what we learn of namor and the origins
of the atlanteans in the mcu as they are
known to make alterations from comics
origins sometimes ign first reported in
august 2021 that riri williams also
known as ironheart would appear in black
panther wakanda forever and the new
trailer confirms it played by dominique
thorne riri williams is a relatively
newer character in marvel comics history
a genius riri is only a teenager when
she begins her studies at the
massachusetts institute of technology
where she creates an advanced suit of
armor in honor of her favorite hero iron
man in the black panther wakanda forever
trailer riri is first greeted in shuri's
lab with a hand slap from the wakandan
royal who seems to know her well later
queen raimondo delivers a speech and
asks have i not given everything as
various scenes play in the background
one of those scenes seems to show riri
forging her iron heart suit of armor as
a piece of heart-shaped armor falls to
the floor it looks like we'll not only
get to meet riri but will also get to
see her in action as the metal clad
superhero it's unclear how large of a
role ironheart will play in the
forthcoming black panther sequel but the
character's future looks bright in the
mcu aside from the riveting performance
by chadwick boseman in the titular role
one of the biggest standouts in black
panther was his nemesis killmonger
michael b jordan's take on the villain
brought a solid performance of a
grounded and somewhat relatable
opposition to t'challa's claim to the
throne the fact that one could watch
black panther and not wholly disagree
with his perspective made killmonger one
of the best villains in the marvel
cinematic universe while fans on reddit
have wondered if they would see jordan
return as t'challa's villainous cousin
his death at the end of the 2018 hit
pick made it unlikely the trailer
however gives us a sneak peek at the new
black panther suit at the end opening
its claws on a beach and preparing for
battle it is almost impossible not to
notice the signature gold details those
elements are not on the suit worn by
t'challa instead they adorn the suit
worn by killmonger in the cousin's
climactic black panther face-off his
suit seems to be back but is killmonger
returning as well check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the mcu are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]